hereis Jackson cozies up to her  boyfriend during a photo shoot and  shares adorable behind-the-scenes pics  the 18 year old daughter of Michael  Jackson snapped sweet photos with her  boyfriend Michael snotty while on set  Thursday she captioned this pic michael  giving her a sweet kiss on the cheek and  had been his groupie for a while now  time to switch roles in the pic a blonde  Paris is wearing sheer black tights  thigh high socks and an oversized a  black sweater Paris drummer boyfriend  took to Instagram posting the same pic  writing how so so proud of this girl of  all the times she tags along to all my  show supporting me it's cool to kick  back and watch her do her magic for a  change I'm so in awe with how incredibly  talented you are baby this is their  second photoshoot in a row last week the  pair posed for an edgy rocker inspired  shoot